[Music]
on this Friday night fighting the flu
cases of influenza and co9 in Canada are
now dropping we're at a year from
prepandemic levels but Health officials
warn of a spike in deadly strep a
infections not guilty hey it feel good
to be
free a retrial clears an Ontario mother
of murdering her severely disabled
daughter more midair scares oh my God
it's on Fire Two aircraft emergencies in
the US forcing one to land on a
highway plus The Art of War it's much
more deeper than art the poignant pieces
on display at a Canadian High
commission global national with far an
Asser reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening and thank you for joining us if
you or someone in your family is feeling
sick right now you're not alone but new
num members from the public health
agency of Canada suggest we may have
turned a corner on this year's cold and
flu season Katherine ward has the
details in our top story tonight so we
had RSV we had c um we had hand foot and
mouth and then over Christmas we got
covid keeping two young kids healthy has
not been easy for Kate Hobson since
September there's always been somebody
that's been sick with the exception I
think of about two weeks new data from
the public health agency of Canada
actually shows infection rates are
starting to improve nationally rates of
covid-19 and influenza are declining and
there are lower than expected rates of
RSV for this time of year from the point
of view of influenza and RSV that we're
at a year from prepandemic levels we're
not seeing the uh very high very early
levels of disease that we saw last year
but Dr Don Shepard notes he is seeing
some Regional differences for covid-19
infections right now in Ontario and
Quebec we have relatively high levels of
disease transmission whereas many of the
other provinces are experiencing fairly
low levels but the good news is that all
of it that's floating around up there is
not translating into huge levels of
hospitalizations huge spikes of
hospitalizations emergency room
physician Dr Steve flindell is feeling
some of that relief fortunately we're
not seeing that the absolute Crush of
people coming in every day that we were
over the last month or so flindell says
he does worry about viral transmission
in crowded waiting rooms we still have a
mandate for masks in our emergency
department and it's still a challenge to
get people to wear their masks because
you can't isolate everybody with
infectious symptoms doctors say it's a
good reminder to make sure you've got
updated shots for added protection even
if you do become ill and have to come in
your chance of being admitted to the ICU
or dying from it are infantes smaller
than somebody has been up to date
Katherine Ward Global News
Toronto despite those encouraging signs
concerns are growing about a spike in
strep a cases BC Health officials say at
least four children with the disease
have died since mid December Ontario's
public health agency recently reported
48 people have died since October
including six young children the number
of annual strep a infections across
Canada recently reached a record high
with more than 4,600 cases in
2023 a Toronto mother accused of
murdering her severely disabled daughter
has been cleared on all charges Cindy
Ali was previously sentenced to life in
prison for the death of her 16-year-old
and what the crown described as a mercy
killing Ally spent more than a decade
fighting to clear her name Katherine
McDonald has covered this case from the
start and reports on today's ruling and
emotional
reaction for the first time in 13 years
Cindy Ali can breathe a sigh of relief
after being found not guilty of
murdering her severely disabled daughter
sonara after to today today it's going
to be our time as a family to start
healing and and and grieving but not
forgetting sinara cuz she's still here
with me it has been a long road to
Justice it's been really tough It's
really this has been a really rough road
for us in February 2011 Cindy called 911
and said two armed massed men had burst
into the family's town home looking for
a package when they left Cindy said she
found her daughter 16-year-old sonara
who suffered from paly in the living
room without Vital Signs 2 days later
sonara died months later Cindy was
charged with manslaughter before the
charges were eventually upgraded to
murder what the crown is alleging is
that the death of sonar Ali was a
planned and deliberate act and we're
alleging that act was perpetrated by
Cindy Ali in 2016 a jury found Cindy
guilty of first-degree murder and she
served four years in prison before the
court of appeal overturned the
conviction and she was released on bail
the court of appeal also ordered a new
Tri trial and Friday she was found not
guilty on all charges I've learned that
uh that uh police uh can uh rush to
judgment as they did in this case and
and that people get charged with crimes
they didn't commit at the second trial
the crown argued Cindy killed sonara to
end her pain the judge rejected that
theory it was a brand new Theory um it
didn't please me at all to suddenly
allege a mercy killing family and
supporters say the verdict means justice
has finally been served hey it feel good
to be
free Cindy's lawyer James Locker who
founded an organization called innocence
Canada to defend the wrongly convicted
says he and his client have yet to
discuss whether she will be seeking
compensation Jeff Katherine McDonald in
Toronto thanks Katherine the French
president's plans to boost his country's
birth rate are sparking outrage critics
call it a push for control over women's
bodies but the problem of an aging
population is not unique to France
Nations around the world face similar
challenges and Tera isri reports on the
concerns and consequences of Canada's
plummeting birth rate France seemed to
be an outlier in Europe it had some of
the highest birth rates in the
EU now they've hit their lowest point
since the end of the second world war
French president Emanuel maon is
pledging to overhaul parental leave to
encourage people to have more
children maon says France will only be
quote stronger if it revives birth rates
last year that number hit
1.68 in Canada it's even lower
1.44 the fertility rate would need to
hit 2.1 to achieve what's known as
replacement level but it's been steadily
declining the total fertility rate has
fallen to an all-time low in Canada the
only thing keeping Canada's population
from shrinking is immigration which has
reached record highs immigration
certainly helps if you're talking about
an aging population but if our birth
rate continues this downward trajectory
our population will be aging at an
accelerated Pace Canadians who have
children are finding it increasingly
expensive to raise them this new mom
from Toronto goes back to work Monday
after a year on maternity leave I would
say it was only enough because my spouse
also works so if we didn't have his
income in addition it would be very
tough especially with you know inflation
going up get the donkey this Nova Scotia
woman doesn't know when she can go back
to work if there's one thing that is
adding majorly to parents stress and
exhaustion and mental load right now it
is the child care crisis the Liberals
rolled out $10 a day child care but
there still aren't enough
spaces Adrien Buckland put her son on a
waight list before he was born a year
later they're still waiting the housing
crisis may also be deterring Canadians
from having children experts on
demographics say many people want to
wait until they own a home before
starting a family but if that's Out Of
Reach having children may feel like one
more luxury they can't afford teria isri
Global News Ottawa after consumer
backlash Canada's largest grer has
reversed its plan to end 50% % discounts
on nearly expired Foods in an emailed
statement to Global News lbla confirms
that customers can expect to see those
50% off stickers returning in the next
few weeks the company said earlier this
week that it would be moving towards 30%
discounts to align with what its
competitors were
offering well after a chilly start to
2024 Canadians are turning up the heat
and we now learning how many homeowners
are taking advantage of ottawa's oil to
heat pump program it's no surprise the
province's most dependent on heating oil
account for most of those applying for
the Federal grant but as Heidi petrac
reports some Advocates say Ottawa needs
to provide better options for Canadians
looking to cash
in technicians like Alex Lavoy are busy
with heat pumps these days we've been
flat out uh probably one of the biggest
challenges is is keeping up with with
customer demand many on the East Coast
rely on furnace oil for Home Heating and
many are also taking up ottawa's offer
of up to $10,000 upfront to switch to
heat pumps that number upped to $115,000
last fall for provinces partnering with
the federal government the point is
really to make a meaningful reduction in
people's energy costs which means we
need to spend enough in each home so
people can get completely off of oil out
of the more than 12 and a half thousand
applications received so far more than
11,000 alone are from Atlantic Canada
and about 6,700 are from Prince Edward
Island almost 850 applications are from
Ontario and Quebec the fewest from the
Prairies with a mere 11 combined BC has
327 the heat pump grants are available
to people living in all provinces but
only those in newf land Prince Edward
Island and Nova Scotia are getting the
grant increase because those provinces
are the only ones with Partnerships to
deliver it I live in a Frozen house cuz
I can barely pay for the gas while this
edmontonian may be on board most Prairie
residents where natural gas is the norm
have turned a cold shoulder to the idea
of switching to heat pumps you still
have a very challenging environment
because you have to overcome uh the
cheap gas and our relatively expensive
electricity prices and while it's still
early days in the 4-year program it
seems ottawa's budget will be blown
recently set at $750 million Canada's
parliament ment budget officer estimates
it could actually cost 797 million it
really needs to be available for
everyone regardless of the heating
Source they use but whether Canadians
switch or not there is no choice to face
the cost of staying warm Heidi pic
Global News
Halifax construction on a new electric
vehicle battery plant in Quebec shut
down today at least temporarily the
multi-billion dollar project was
announced last last fall touting plans
to produce some of the greenest
batteries in the world but environmental
groups are fighting the project the site
is located about 25 kilometers east of
Montreal and as Mike Armstrong explains
the work which had barely begun is now
on
hold this site is now at a standstill
Crews had been cutting down trees
they're now waiting to see when or if
they'll start up
again instead it's lawyers at the
Montreal Courthouse who've been busy
right now the work is suspended so we're
relieved about that Mark bishai
represents an environmental group
fighting the north volt project it says
it would mean destroying Wetlands on the
site and while the north volt project
has been approved by the province it
says another project for the same site
was denied over environmental concerns
so far from the few documents that we do
have it does seem like a double
standard the north Vault project was
announced with great Fanfare last fall
$7 billion Investments tend to attract
politicians from every level welcome to
North EST Ino Sweden northal is a
Swedish company that produces lithium
ion batteries the Quebec plant is slated
to open in 2026 and create about 3,000
jobs to Lure North Vault The Province
and the federal government put up 2.7
billion for the
construction now the land actually
housed a fact Factory in the past Cil
produced paint for decades and even
explosives during the second world war
but critics say the site is now home to
endangered turtles and that rules were
changed to allow the project it was
greenlit without provincial
environmental hearings we just want the
mechanism that are basically in our laws
and and the way that we should work be
respected by the
government now Friday's hearing was for
opponents to request a court injunction
halting work on the site the company
asked to delay the proceedings until
Tuesday but stopped anyway in a
statement to Global News North folt says
it's suspended work out of respect for
the judicial process the two sides will
be back in court next week Mike
Armstrong Global News
Montreal a Ukrainian drone attack
sparked a large fire at an oil Depot in
Russia around 6,000 cubic meters of oil
were set Ablaze during the strike on a
city City near the Russian Ukrainian
border no one was injured just yesterday
there was a similar drone strike at
another oil facility in St
Petersburg when a roadway becomes a
Runway coming up the startling scene
near America's capital plus major
layoffs at Sports
Illustrated oh my God it's on
fire a frightening sight in the sky over
Florida last night as flames were seen
shooting out of a plane shortly after it
took off from Miami's International
Airport the Boeing 747 cargo plane made
an emergency landing no injuries were
reported the US Federal Aviation
Administration and Atlas Air the company
that owns the aircraft now say that a
full investigation is
underway and near Washington DC another
miraculous Landing this Cessna was
forced to land on a snowy Virginia
Highway shortly after takeoff today the
plane visibly damaged after colliding
with Highway guard rails during the
emergency landing incredibly all seven
people on board reportedly walked away
without injury the cause of that crash
is also being
investigated the publisher of Sports
Illustrated says it's planning to lay
off a significant portion if not all of
the Outlet's Union represented staff the
publisher says the owner authentic
Brands group revoked its marketing
license after it failed to make a
quarterly payment of nearly $4 million
it's been a difficult few months for
Sports Illustrated it was recently
accused of trying to pass off AI
generated content as though it had been
produced by
humans sticking the landing still ahead
Japan's Precision mission on the lunar
surface the first US spacecraft to
attempt a moon landing in five decades
soared hundreds of thousands of
kilometers through space before meeting
a fiery end that's astrobotics paragen
lunarlander firing its thrusters on its
way to re-entry before burning up an
Earth's atmosphere over the South
Pacific Ocean the privately built
spacecraft developed under a contract
with NASA was designed to settle on the
moon shortly after launching into orbit
on January the eth but the Lander
suffered a fuel leak forcing its
operators to scrap the entire Mission
Japan had better luck becoming the fifth
country to land a spacecraft on the moon
the unmanned slim Lander is believed to
have made one of the most precise moon
landings ever as Jackson prco reports
Japan believes the technology will be a
powerful tool in future interplanetary
exploration after a landing sequence
dubbed 20 minutes of
Terror Japan's space agency announced
mission accomplished we believe that the
soft learning itself was successful has
been activated only a handful of
countries have ever managed to land on
the moon Japan is now one of them and
this was no ordinary touchdown the smart
Lander for investigating moon or slim
had been nicknamed the moon sniper
because it's designed to land on target
with more Precision than any other
robotic spacecraft remember there's no
GPS on the
moon after a journey of more than 1.3
million kilm Slim's Target Landing Zone
was only 100 m wide about the length of
a football field
the private American paragr Lander which
abandoned its mission after a fuel leak
had planned to land anywhere within a
range of several kilometers you can see
the stars and stries the first man moon
mission Apollo 11 missed its Target by
over 6 kilm if you can reliably land
exactly where you want you can then
better fine-tune and specialize payloads
and missions to take advantage of what
to believe to be the unique properties
of wherever it is you want to go it's a
big step for future space Miss that
might look to tap into precious
resources on the moon or elsewhere and
Japan has successfully landed probes on
Tiny asteroids twice with the same goal
in
mind back on the moon there is a problem
with slim solar panels they aren't
generating power backup batteries are
working for now and the mission managed
to successfully deploy two small Rovers
one that hops and one that rolls the
goal is to send back pictures of the
probe to verify if it's stuck its
incredible Landing despite the slim odds
Jackson prco Global News
Washington from armor to Art up next how
Ukraine's remnants of War are being
transformed for a good
cause as we approach the twoyear mark of
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
protective gear worn by Ukrainian
soldiers is getting a second life
riddled with bullets and shrapnel
artists have transformed the body armor
into art to tell the story of the war
Crystal Gans Singh takes us inside the
display at the Canadian High Commission
in
London bathed in light adorned with
color every piece linked to the life of
a Ukrainian Soldier a life saved by an
armored plate when you're looking at
this it's it's so much more than than
art than absolutely this is it
transcends art it's much more deeper
than art but to feel that uh emotional
connection you probably have to have the
experience of feeling the war
firstand battling against a fullscale
Russian invasion for nearly 2 years
what has left its mark on every aspect
of life in UK Ukraine families torn
apart homes destroyed lives and
bodies forever changed all what we do
it's a contribution of of the defense of
Ukraine yuk says his favorite pieces are
from Ukrainian children their work like
the rest reflects their culture their
personalities and the realities of War
art armor was launched in 2022
originally with works by famous local
artists as a fundraiser for the
Ukrainian armed forces the terrifying
marks of those bullets and
shrapnel as you can see very visibly on
all of these plates tell the story of
the ongoing war in Ukraine better than
any words possibly could some of the
pieces will eventually be auctioned off
with proceeds going towards more
protective gear Rehabilitation efforts
and Dem mining projects Canada house in
London is the last stop of the
exhibition's European tour but it's not
the end organizers are looking for
artists anywhere in the world with an
eye for creating Beauty from
brutality Crystal ganing Global News
London and that is global national for
this Friday night I'm Jeff simple
tonight's your Canada is this icy
Shoreline on Ontario thanks for watching
hope to see you back here again tomorrow
have a great
[Music]
night